- The market for cultural art is huge.
Unfortunately, almost all the native art
that you find either online or in stores
features fake Native American art.
When I walk into a store
and I see cultural art
from my community that's counterfeit,
it feels like a family photo
on a product in a store.
It feels that personal to me,
and I wanted to do something about it.
(inspirational music)
My name's Louie Gong.
I'm a NookSack tribal member,
and I'm the founder of Eighth Generation,
which is based at Pike
Place Market in Seattle.
When I walk through the mall,
almost every store has
native art on products in it,
and not one of those products
is connected to a native artist.
To me, that represents a huge problem,
and Eighth Generation tries
to address that problem
by creating actual opportunities
for cultural artists to develop products.
I'm a self-taught artist,
and about 10 years ago
I started doing art by
customizing a pair of shoes,
and I had developed a really
strong, organic following
from doing that work.
We know that people
want to but Native art,
so that eventually became the foundation
of Eighth Generation.
We have about 15 different
business relationships
with makers within two
miles of Pike Place Market.
When you buy products featuring
art done by native people
and produced by native-owned companies,
you're strengthening the cultural art
and the communities
whose artwork you like.
We're the first native-owned company
to offer wool blankets.
This is important, because
the aesthetic of wool blankets
has largely been native.
When people think of wool blankets,
they think of native art.
I think people are used
to seeing native people
in one of three categories.
We're typically a charity
project, or a symbol of history,
or a symbol of the natural environment.
We're planting a seed about
who native people really are,
and so when they walk in the door,
the message that gets conveyed
is that we're alive and we're thriving.
And that contradicts
what people want to think
about native people.